Corea del Norte Ya disparado un número
récord de misiles este año el último se
produce justo un día antes del inicio
los ejercicios militares conjuntos de
Corea del Sur y Estados Unidos El misil
balístico de corto alcance lanzado por
Corea del Norte voló esta vez a unos 600
kilómetros a una altitud de 60
kilómetros y una velocidad de match 5 el
proyectil fue lanzado desde la zona de
taechón en el oeste del país voló a
través de la Península coreana y cayó en
aguas cercanas a la zona económica
exclusiva de Japón
este misil balístico puede haber tomado
una trayectoria de vuelo irregular
actualmente estamos recogiendo y
analizando la información pertinente
muchos de los misiles de corto alcance
probados por Corea del Norte en los
últimos años han sido diseñados para
evadir las defensas antimisiles
maniobrando durante el vuelo a Baja
altura
el comandante de Estados Unidos para el
Indo Pacífico señaló que lanzamiento no
supone una amenaza inmediata para su
personal o su territorio ni para sus
aliados pero que pone de manifiesto el
impacto desestabilizador de los
programas armamentísticos de Corea del
Norte El portaaviones de propulsión
nuclear estadounidense Us Ronald Reagan
llegó a usar el viernes para practicar
unos ejercicios militares de 4 días con
las fuerzas surcoreanas que comienzan el
lunes
ha criticado repetidamente los
ejercicios conjuntos de Estados Unidos y
Corea del Sur como prueba de su política
hostil que amenaza su soberanía
[Música]